[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's
facts 800-463-7297
pastor john ross
hello friends how about an amazing fact
in 1967 the united nations adopted an
international outer space treaty
forbidding all nations from claiming the
moon or any part of space's territory
however the treaty failed to mention
anything about private individuals
claiming ownership to other planets or
moons
so early in the 1980s dennis hope from
nevada sent letters to the united
nations
the united states the soviet union and
informed them that he was claiming
ownership to all lunar surfaces in our
solar system aside from the earth
he even gave them an opportunity to
respond if they had objections
but he never heard a word from them
for nearly 40 years now hope has been
selling land plots on the moon and mars
for the price of about 20 dollars an
acre
he has been pursuing this not just as a
novelty sale but as a serious real
estate transaction complete with land
titles covenants and bylaws
although others are now in the same
business
hope has earned more than 10 million
dollars selling land on planets he has
never visited
it seems that selling land out of this
world is a profitable business venture
but did you know friends that the bible
teaches that you can own heavenly real
estate for free
jesus said in my father's house there
are many mansions if it were not so i
would have told you
i go to prepare a place for you and if i
go and prepare a place for you i will
come again and receive you unto myself
that where i am there you may be also as
john 14 verse 2 and 3. you know pastor
carlos it's amazing how people are
willing to buy something that they've
never seen on another planet in
particular here the moon and it seems
like the person who is selling
property on the moon is making real good
money whether that's actually going to
stand up in court i don't know but at
least for now he's making a lot of money
yeah and then jesus is offering us
something for free and many people
reject that a lot better than a piece of
land on the moon on mars right yeah he's
offering us a mansion
made in heaven and the bible tells us
that you know the new jerusalem is a
splendid city something that we can't
even begin to imagine
a streets are made of gold
beautiful gates and there is a mansion a
home specifically made by christ for the
redeemed you know we have a free gift
that we want to share with anyone who
calls and asks it's about this reward
that jesus is preparing for those that
love him and it's a book called heaven
is it for real and this is our free
offer all you need to do is call and ask
for that again the book is called heaven
is it for real and you can call the
number 1-800-835-6747
and you can ask for offer number 189 or
just ask for the book by name heaven is
it for real you know pastor carlos it's
interesting part of the reason why i did
this fact on the moon is that there's a
lot of excitement right now about
a visit of the moon apparently tomorrow
this is sunday evening but i believe
early monday morning
on
from florida
from the kennedy space center
they're going to launch a rocket called
artemis 1 which i believe is one of the
biggest rockets if not the biggest
rocket that has ever been built and it's
going to go to the moon it's an unmanned
rocket but it's going to orbit the moon
and even go further than the moon and
then come back to the earth
and this is all in preparation for a
manned trip back to the moon in the next
couple years
yeah and they're ready by talking about
colonizing mars
that's why i want to use the moon as a
as a stepping stone to mars so
you know the good news is that we get to
travel through space past the moon past
mars and then past the
planets when when jesus comes and we
take that heavenly journey to the new
jerusalem so friends call and ask for
that book we'll be happy to send it to
you
before we go to the phone lines my name
is john ross pastor doug is out this
evening
but we are open for your bible questions
if you have a bible related question the
number here to the studio is
800-463-7297
we'll also give you another number that
is our free uh offer it's 800-835-6747
and if you have a bible-related question
we'd love to hear from you tonight i'm
pastor carlos though before we go to the
phone lines let's start with the word of
prayer
father we thank you for uh just the
privilege and the honor of coming
together and spending time in your word
and
we know there are many people with many
questions we ask that you they come join
us and we ask that your spirit guide us
to give them the biblical answers
for the many questions that may arise
and so we thank you again for this
privilege and this honor and we ask this
in jesus name amen amen
all right well i think our phone lines
are open who do we have first yes sheena
from tennessee welcome to bible answers
live
good evening hello hi sheena
hey how are you doing well
good i'm calling in a question for my
husband he's reading in
mark chapter 10.
specifically the question comes from
verse 17 to 19.
so when jesus was asked what shall i do
that i may inherit eternal life in verse
17 and then 19 he responds or replies
with to know the commandments and he
lists six of them why did he only
mention six out of the ten oh good
question well of course there's ten
commandments the ten commandments are
divided into two parts the first four of
the ten commandments have to do with our
relationship with god have no other gods
before him don't worship idols don't
take his name in vain remember the
sabbath to keep it holy the last six of
the ten commandments have to do with our
relationship with our fellow man which
is honoring our parents not murder don't
commit adultery don't lie don't steal
and don't covet now the commandments
that we find mentioned here jesus is not
addressing any of the first four
commandments
but he's pointing out the last six that
has to do with his relationship with his
fellow man because it appears that that
seems to be the sensitive area a part of
his life that he was struggling to let
go of
because he responds in verse 20 and he
says all of these things i've kept from
my youth but then jesus narrows in and
he says one thing you lack go sell what
you have and give it to the poor and you
shall have treasury in heaven so quite
possibly that the sin that this rich
young ruler was struggling with was
pride he felt superior to others he was
rich he was young he was a ruler so he
had influence and power
and he looked down on others and jesus
is emphasizing that in order to truly
keep the law it's not just an outward
behavior but it has to do with the heart
love for god love for our fellow man is
the motivation for obedience to god's
commandments and that was the point that
he was lacking love for his fellow man
and that's why jesus mentioned those
last six
that makes sense thank you all right
good question thanks for calling you
know we do have a lesson called written
in stone and it's all about the ten
commandments and we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who's wondering about the
law of god is it still binding and
relevant for christians today
uh all you need to do is call and ask
the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for one of the amazing
facts study guides it's called written
in stone we'll be happy to send it to
anyone in north america if you're
listening outside of north america just
visit the amazing facts website just
amazingfacts.org
you'll be able to read that lesson for
free you can even sign up for the
amazing facts free online bible course
and you will be blessed
all right pastor who do we have next
next we have anthony from new york you
are live on bible answers live
hello good evening pastor hi
um my question comes from first samuel
chapter 11.
um i don't know if you want me to read
it or if you want to read it
first samuel
chapter 1 chapter 1 verse 1
first samuel chapter 1 verse 11. let's
see
all right it says then she made a vowel
and she said o lord of hosts if you will
indeed look upon my affliction or the
affliction of your maidservant and
remember me and
not forget your maidservant but will
give your maidservant a male child then
i'll give in to the lord all the days of
his life and no razor shall come upon
his head
yes so this sounds like
samuel i was going to be raised by
hannah as a nazarene correct and
i know that same was for samson and
other men in the bible
um i guess my question is what is the
purpose of being raised as a nazarene
and is there an application for us today
where you know maybe we can raise our
children as nazarenes for that same
purpose okay well that's a good question
you know i think having the nazarite vow
was a commitment that you were in
full-time ministry of full-time service
for the lord you're on a special god
given aaron and mission now all of the
israelites were to live
to bring glory to god they were to serve
god there were certain
feasts that they were to attend uh
certain laws that they were to abide by
but the nazirites are those who are
taking the nazarite vow and a nazarite
vial wasn't necessarily for someone's
entire life you could do it for a few
years or for a limited period of time or
you could be committed for a much longer
period of time and we have some of these
bible characters that were committed for
a much longer period of time but it
simply meant that you were being set
apart for a special work of ministry for
the lord
now i think in our terms today we do do
something similar if somebody is going
to full-time ministry
and they're going to be committed
full-time in ministry whether it's
pastoral ministry or evangelism or even
working in a in a local church capacity
in some type of bible work full-time
ministry we do sometimes i have an
ordination service where we will set
somebody apart
for the gospel work which is similar in
some extent to that of a nazarene
we can also dedicate our children
uh shortly after birth it's different
it's not baptizing but it's dedicating
our children
uh in a special way asking that the lord
would lead and guide in their life and
make clear
what the work is that god would have
them to do because god's got to work for
for all of us all of us who claim to be
christians so the nazarite vow today
would be in a little bit of a different
form i think baptism also helps to
fulfill some of what that nazarite
vow was and then also ordination
ordaining someone to a particular work
of ministry that would also uh be the
same as as the nazirite val
okay yes that's helpful so
you know the the
not cutting hair and um
uh
um
not you know touching anything from the
vine like wine or anything like that
that wouldn't necessarily
you know does doing those things make no
you has a right that wouldn't yes
that wouldn't make their life
that wouldn't have value in today's
world um of course back in bible times
people understood what that meant when
somebody didn't cut their hair and they
didn't eat grapes or drink grape juice
people are aware of what that is but in
our context today it wouldn't be of any
value
somebody doesn't cut their hair people
don't realize that they've made some
kind of a vowel
rather a vowel that's made is something
that you commit your life to it's it's
not something that you you wear it's not
something
that you um necessarily eat or don't eat
well the bible does give us guidelines
as to what is helpful to eat and what
what we shouldn't eat
okay i understand thank you very much
all right thanks for your call anthony
thank you
david from california your bible answers
live
hi david welcome to the program hello
thank you this is david from fresno um
two questions what was god doing
and where was he during the dinosaur
now it's way off but then it's all kinds
of dinosaurs all right um well the
dinosaurs did live you know we got the
fossilized bones of them but they lived
before the flood
and the reasons we don't have dinosaurs
today is because they were destroyed by
the flood there was a change in our
atmosphere there was a change in our
climate and a lot of the animals that
were able to live and thrive before the
flood
after the flood couldn't live in the
changed environment
um you look back in the fossil record
and even the dragonflies were much
bigger than we have them now and the
animals were a lot bigger than we have
now the insects were bigger so the whole
environment was different before the
flood but they were destroyed at the
time of the flood we know in his family
were in the ark and some of the animals
the animals came into the ark as well
and then there were animals that came
into the ark that probably became
extinct sometime after the flood like
the woolly mammoth we know that they
lived after the flood
so um yeah the dinosaurs were destroyed
during the time of the flood and that's
why we have the fossilized bones and we
can dig them up and look at them what
address what i just cannot find that um
sorry what was the question
what address can i find that on in the
bible
yeah does the bible say anything about
that yes it does there is an interesting
verse that you find in job job chapter
40 verse 18 talks about an animal and
the animal's name is behemoth and you
can read the description in chapter 40
it says that he eats
grass like an ox he talks about him
being very big and strong his tail is
like a cedar
he is
big legs strong
legs talks about them being as bronze
these ribs are like bars of iron
now we don't have an animal that is
really going to meet this description
alive today so apparently job
it was one of the oldest books written
in the bible was aware of these large
animals that lived before the flood and
behemoth is one of them and then there's
another one by the name of leviathan
that you also read about in the book of
job so there are references to these
very big creatures these dinosaur-like
animals
uh in the bible they lived before the
flood well and also in the ocean
yes whales big whales and yes all kinds
of interesting animals so
all right well thank you for your call
david who do we have next
next we have joel joel from north
carolina i believe welcome joel
hi pastors
hi joel
um
when and who wrote the book of
lamentations
all right who wrote the book of
lamentations the time of lamentations
was written right around the time of um
the exodus it was written by jeremiah
the prophet
it was actually before the destruction
of of jerusalem by the babylonians
or connected with that same time period
i think actually maybe it's right around
after the destruction of jerusalem by
the babylonians but that's the time
frame and lamentations is jeremiah the
prophet he's lamenting or he's weeping
because of the sins of israel and
because of the judgments that was coming
upon judah and upon jerusalem which
eventually was the destruction that
occurred
so it's right around that time period if
you want to date it's somewhere around
probably 610 bc
because jerusalem fell in 605 bc so
somewhere around that time period 605
610 written by jeremiah the prophet
okay thank you
all right thanks you're cool joel
next we have joey from toronto canada
welcome joey to bible answers live
yes good evening pastor ross how are you
i'm doing well thanks for your call joey
yes my i have a
bible
question we have been studying
hebrews i believe hebrews chapter 10 and
talks about the heavenly sanctuary
and my my question is how come it was
never mentioned by jesus in the gospels
at all
because i
it makes me wonder if there really is a
heavenly sanctuary like the one that
moses built
okay yes the answer to that is there
heavenly sanctuary the answer to that is
absolutely yes and the book of hebrews
makes that very clear it talks about
jesus our high priest who is ministering
for us in the heavenly sanctuary not
built with human hands
but a temple that god built now why
doesn't jesus reference the sanctuary
directly when he was on the earth well
there were three phases to christ's
ministry just like the sanctuary was
compro comprised of three parts you had
the courtyard area where the animal was
sacrificed then you had the holy place
and the most holy place which was inside
the intersection of that
so the courtyard and everything related
to the courtyard the sacrificing of the
lamb and so on that refers to christ's
earthly ministry and when jesus was on
the earth that was the focus i
understand that's why he came i
understand so when jesus ascended to
heaven he began his high priestly
ministry and that's why you find in the
book of revelation revelation chapter 1
describes jesus wearing a high priest
robe and he's standing amongst the
candlesticks which is the first
compartment of the hefny sanctuary
hebrews talks about jesus our great high
priest he's ministering for us in the
temple not made with human hands
so the focus of the heavenly sanctuary
doesn't really occur until after
christ's work on the earth is finished
and he ascends up to heaven and he
begins his high priestly ministry
does that does that make sense joey
no but i have never found any references
at all in the gospels how come it was
never mentioned by jesus at all
well not everything that jesus uh
mentions or not everything that jesus
does not mention
doesn't mean that it's not real or it's
not it's not true
there were different truths that were
being presented at different times and
at the time that jesus was here he was
the focus jesus said destroy this temple
in three days i'll raise it up again and
he's talking about himself and his
mission and his teaching that he had
come to do
uh the sanctuary work and him as a high
priest in heaven doesn't really take
front and center stage until after his
ascension
but jesus communicated these truths to
paul and the other apostles through the
inspiration of the holy spirit so it's
just as trustworthy the account that we
find in hebrews as anything that jesus
would say or anything that the apostles
wrote in the gospels it's just different
times and different emphasis for those
times
all right thank you for your call joey
you know we do have a study guide
talking about the sanctuary i'm trying
to think i think it uh
it's uh god drew the plans that's what
it's called there's 17 years number 17
you can call and ask for that the number
is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the study guide it's
called god drew the plans it's all about
the sanctuary you've got the earthly
sanctuary that is a type of the heavenly
sanctuary and i'll go into much more
detail on that who do we have next next
we have eric from canada welcome eric
hello hi eric you're on the air
um yes um i called before so this is my
second time
yes
personal question
you know
um trouble with like the um passage of
the bible you know where elisha um was
going somewhere and then like a group of
boys
were mocking him or calling him like a
body yes um why is it that he then you
know called you know
cursed them and then bears came to maul
them okay i mean it's pretty violent
okay like someone is like in the book of
joshua there's a lot of violence yeah
you know against them
and maybe like other people in the
territory of israel you know i i it
troubles me sometimes
yeah sure let's talk about that case
that you just quoted uh elisha and
elijah so elijah just ascended to heaven
in a fiery chariot
and elisha was now received a double
portion of the spirit and he was to do
the work that elijah did elijah had
considerable influence over israel over
the people because the lord had used him
in a mighty way he was powerful in his
work
people didn't look at elisha with the
same status as elijah and it was
important that people realize that the
israelites realized that elisha was just
as much cold to do the work of god as
elijah did and so here elijah is he's
going up a road and apparently people
heard about elijah going to heaven there
were some young boys now when the bible
says youth it's not talking about you
know five six-year-olds it's talking
about probably young teenagers so
uh or even teenagers could be 16 17 18
years of age
and they began to mock elisha
in the hearing of the people in the
village there and they said go up old
man meaning they were saying like elijah
had gone to heaven they were saying
elisha why don't you also go up why
don't you go to heaven and they mocked
him
and it was important at that point that
people realized that he was especially
called by god
and these bears came out and maul mauled
the young men we don't have a record of
them being killed
but a lesson had to be taught and these
weren't
kids these were young you know young men
that had influence and the word quickly
spread that elisha has just as much
authority and he's working just as much
for god as elijah did
elijah did and that actually helped in
doing the work that elisha was called to
do so there was there was reason for
that and of course those those kids
deserve that they shouldn't be mocking a
prophet and that's not a good thing to
do
and then also why is there so much
violence in the old testament in joshua
well the bible tells us that when god
brought israel into the promised land he
had given them the nations that were
conquered by israel he had given them
time to repent 400 years from the time
of abraham to when the israelites
returned to the land of promise
uh those nations were so steeped in
idolatry and wickedness uh they were
sacrificing their children through the
fire to marduk and other gods and
there's actually archaeological finds
one recent archaeological find
found these these clay jars very big
filled with children's bones um from
the various pagan nations that were
offering
their children to to these pagan gods so
there was so much wickedness taking
place in the land that a time of
judgment had come
almost like the flood before you know
that we need to deluvian world because
of their sins
they were wiped out there was also a
judgment that came upon those pagan
nations of
israel all right who do we have next
next we have joel from tennessee joelle
you are live welcome
my question personally is how do you
know god's will because sometimes i
think
uh he wants me to go one way and then
i'm not what i'm not sure whether i go
that way or not so how do you know god's
will oh okay good question i think first
of all you want to make sure that what
it is you want to do is in line with
what you understand to be truth in the
bible so
you know it begins with the law and the
testimony according to the scriptures so
you don't want to do something that's
contradicting the bible god will never
leave us lead us contrary to what the
bible says but let's say there's two
good choices and you're trying to decide
which way do you want to go probably the
next step is you pray about it you ask
the lord to lead and then you seek godly
counsel so you might want to speak to
people that you know
are good christians and get their input
and their thoughts
and then pray for providence pray that
god will open doors and close doors
based upon what his will is
after all if you believe that god is
wanting to lead you into his will and
you sincerely are seeking to do his will
then you can trust his providence that
if he opens up a door and things seem to
be going this way then you you carefully
and humbly follow the direction that god
is leading and if he changes and he
directs you another way then you you
follow that leading so
those are the things you want to do make
sure that it's in harmony with the word
of god you want to spend time in prayer
asking for the spirit to guide you you
want to counsel with godly people and
get their their guidance and then
thirdly you want to pray that god would
just open the right doors and pray that
he would close the doors that he doesn't
want you to follow
and then trust his leading
thank you all right thank you very help
thanks for your call you know we do have
a book called determining the will of
god and we'll send it to anyone for free
that's a good question i mean what do
you do in some situations
if you'd like to receive the book the
number to call is 800-835-6747
and again just ask for the book it's
called determining the will of god i'll
be happy to send it to anyone here in
north america all right who do we have
next brenda from ohio you are on the air
welcome
hi thank you for taking my call um
um my mom and i both listened to making
facts quite a bit and she mentioned to
me yesterday about
she heard that uh pastor bachelor
thought that
maybe in the bible days
men for instance didn't really mature
until they were like 80 to 100 years old
and um i can't remember why that came up
the thought i had was well then
did that mean that mary was not a
teenager when she
gave birth to christ
i kind of thought she was very young
like 14 15 maybe she was older that's my
question okay good question yes with
reference to people maturing older in
bible times i think pastor doug's
reference to that was before the flood
and the reason for that is you find that
people lived a lot longer before the
flood often they wouldn't get married
until 200 years or
80 or 90 years old
but that was before the flood after the
flood and especially the time of christ
yes people getting married a lot younger
and so it was true men were a little
older when they typically got married
they'd have a career they'd know what
they're doing
woman would marry younger and uh mary
was a young girl i don't think she was
as young as you know 13 14 15 years old
she was probably either late teens or
early 20s
it appears that joseph was older than
her because at the time that christ
began his public ministry at 30
joseph was out of the you know off the
scene he had died at that point
um so yes mary was probably in a in a
late teens maybe early 20s somewhere in
there
when when she had jesus
okay thank you very much all right
thanks for your question
well pastor carlos i don't think we have
time for another call you hear the music
playing in the background friends we're
we're not ending the program by any
means we've got another half an hour of
bible questions but we are going to take
a short break and then we'll be back for
more bible questions so stay tuned we'll
be right back
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
can't get enough amazing facts bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth-filled
programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aftv.org
at aftv.org
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aftv.org
life's a curious thing
i mean just when things seem under
control wham you're hit with something
new
your marriage is good
suddenly it's on the brink of divorce
that job's great and then it's gone and
so is your life savings
you feel healthy
then your doctor gives the bad news
what's coming next
you could look to the stars but they
don't have the answers
but this does
the prophecy study bible by amazing
facts
this bible special its 27 personal study
guides lead you on a life-changing
journey through god's word
to discover real answers to life's
questions
from health and relationships to family
and future
the hopes in here
get your amazing facts prophecy study
bible today by calling 800-538-720
[Music]
or visit afbookstore.com
would you like to know god's plan for
our troubled world and solutions for
your life's challenges beautifully
redesigned and updated amazing facts 27
bible study guides provide
straightforward bible-based answers that
are enlightening encouraging and easy to
understand giving you real relevant
bible answers to questions like how can
i have healthier relationships when will
jesus come and much more order yours
today by visiting afbookstore.com
or by calling
a clearer 800-538-7275 of god and his
plan to save you so what are you waiting
for get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hello friends welcome back to bible
answers live a live interactive
international bible study my name is
john ross pastor doug is out this
evening but also joining me here in the
studio is pastor carlos pastor carlos is
one of our team members at amazing facts
he actually is one of the speakers for
amazing facts and you focus on spanish
work in a particular way yeah that's
right we're excited about that and we're
starting uh
start amazing facts latino social media
tv programs soon so yeah so where do
people go if they want to learn more
amazing facts latino.org
or they can go on amazingfacts.org and
there's a there's a link
at the top right hand for the latino
they can connect there all right very
good some exciting things happening with
the latino work at amazing facts well
friends if you have a bible question the
phone line's open the number to call is
that'll get your 800-463-7297 question
here on the air this evening
who do we have next
next we have rosanna from new york
hello rosanna
hello thank you guys
my question is
in revelation the first three chapters
jesus explained that the
the seven stars in his right hand are
the angels and the lampstands are the
churches so why does when he writes the
letters why is he referring
uh he's
he's he starts the letters off to the
angel of athens like he names each
church but he's writing to the angels as
opposed to the people
okay good question now the word there
angel that we find in in the greek is
angelos it literally means messenger
and it's kind of nice to think that yes
there are angels assigned to different
churches i like that idea but the word
angelos also has a broader application
especially in the book of revelation it
means messenger or leader and so the
letters written to the seven churches
were written to the leaders of the
churches
and they were the ones that would share
the message to the rest of the
congregation that's why there is a
blessing for those who hear the words of
the prophecy those who read the words of
the prophecy and those who keep the
words of the prophecy
so when the letter came the first letter
was addressed the church of ephesus so
john wrote the letter on the island of
patmos who was mailed to the church of
ephesus
and one
church service the elder of the church
the one in charge got up and he read the
letter that had just come from their
beloved john who was the past of the
church of ephesus before he was taken to
patmos
he would read the letter and then it was
carefully copied by hand and then it was
sent to the next church to the church of
smyrna and they did the same thing in
that church they read the letter they
copied it and they sent it to the next
church and so the letter worked its way
around all seven of the churches
and then i'm sure it was seen to all of
the churches at least those in the area
of turkey and copied and multiplied and
that's how we have it today so the angel
there simply means the leader or the
messenger that is to bring the message
to the church we also have the three
angels messages in revelation chapter
14. and the three angels of revelation
14 really represent god's people at the
end of time that are taking the
everlasting gospel to every nation
kindred tongue and people so an angel
there means messenger
thank you so much i appreciate that
oh my goodness yes thank you all right
you're welcome thanks for your call
next we have david from michigan david
welcome back to bible answers live
hi pastor
hello
yes hello hi hi pastors um good evening
um heber chapter six um says that we
should move on
unto perfection not laying again the
foundation
of the doctrine of baptisms and other
things
just asking a question about how
we can
move on
from
the doctrine of infant baptism that's
present i know there's some divisions
regarding that how do we understand um
infant baptism okay good question now in
the context here we have paul who wrote
the book of hebrews and he's writing to
believers
and apparently this is this is a
follow-up it's not something brand new
because in chapter six verse one he says
therefore leaving the discussion of the
elementary principles these are things
that they had already studied
of christ let's go on to perfection
meaning fullness of full understanding
of bible truth not laying again the
foundation of repentance from dead works
because that already been discussed in
other letters and in sermons
and faith towards god the doctrine of
baptism the laying on of hands the
resurrection from the dead and eternal
judgment and he says these things will
do if god permits meaning if they have
enough time and he's writing the letter
and he wants to talk more about the
priestly ministry of jesus that's really
the focus of hebrews so when he says
going on it's not meaning that those are
not important doctrines it's meaning
that paul had already discussed those
doctrines he'd already provided some
guidance
on those doctrines
now specifically about the doctrine of
baptism you know if you look at what the
bible teaches on baptism baptism
needs to follow repentance and an infant
can't repent
so baptism needs to be done when a
person is old enough to recognize that
they're a sinner to come to christ and
ask him for forgiveness
and to commit their life publicly saying
i'm following jesus and that is through
baptism so infant baptism is not a
teaching in the bible it kind of came in
pastor carlos during the dark ages
uh part of the problem at that time is
there was so many babies were dying and
the false teaching was prominent that if
you weren't baptized
you had no chance yeah of of uh you know
salvation or eternal life and so the
custom grew of baptizing children as
soon as possible but that's what the
bible teaches it doesn't mean that if
you're not baptized you can't be saved
and you're a baby and you die but
baptism is a public profession of christ
and and that's why it's so important
does that uh does that make sense
it does make sense i know i have other
questions in my mind like i know paul
also writes in his letter to the romans
he says you know repentance
is a gift from god and um
that it's something that
we don't always perform so
um when that gift is performed um
those
that will baptism well that will be
something that god will lead us into
doing after he gives us repentance or
after yes
on the day of pentecost when peter got
up and preached and the people said what
do we need to do to be safe peter
responded says repent and be baptized in
the name of jesus so you've got
repentance that precedes baptism baptism
is the public proclamation of your
decision that you follow in christ
yes
all right
well thanks for your call david you know
we do have a book it's called baptism is
it really necessary and we'll be happy
to send this to anyone who calls and
asks all you need to do is call the
number 800-835-6747
and ask for the book it's called baptism
is it really necessary pastor carlos i
know you've been involved in a number of
baptisms it's a it's a beautiful thing
to see somebody make that public
decision to follow christ amen it's a
it's gorgeous how you come out of the
water and you're it's like i love taking
showers yeah so that cleanness of
putting your past life behind you and
starting a new life in christ now you've
been involved in a number of baptisms
what was the uh what was the most
special baptism that you actually uh did
i know you were baptized of course but
other than that you've done a number of
meetings you've baptized a lot of people
what was the most
specialist baptism that's easy baptizing
my mother that's right that's what i was
thinking about you did a series of
meetings and your mother made a decision
and she was baptized hey man that's a
special thing amen all right who do we
have next
next we have uh
robert from north carolina
hi robert welcome to the program
hey pastor doug i'm here pastor ross and
i passed carlos um yes i had a question
about
uh
sorry brain freeze i had a question
about uh tide
but i
changed my mind while i was on hold i
wanted to ask about what does it mean in
the bible where
it says the word does not die because it
might as far as my belief everything
that goes to lake of fire is burnt up
it's gone it should be no more yes
the the phrase the worm does not die is
a reference to the city dump that was
outside of jerusalem
so
in the valley outside of jerusalem all
the refuse would be thrown there was
constant fires burning they would even
throw dead animals in there and even the
bodies of criminals sometimes
uh so just like a city dump outside of
the city now
you know at least a number of years ago
there would always be fire burning the
smoke would always be ascending it was
always a smelly place there were worms
that were devouring you know the flesh
of dead animals or whatever it might be
so the context there the imagery that's
used is the city dump meaning there is
no more value it's a it's a symbolic
reference to the final destruction of
the wicked it's not talking about a
literal worm that's going to be in the
lake of fire that's going to be eating
people that's not biblical it's just an
idiomatic expression that was used and
it was common to the to the people when
you spoke about the place where
the worm doesn't die you know you're
talking about the city dump and it means
a place where you throw refuge
hopefully that helps robert who do we
have next
next we have jeremiah from texas welcome
jeremiah to bible answers live
hello pastor ross and pastor carlos
thank you for taking my call
yes how can we help you
yeah my question uh is about fasting
okay
several times um in the bible whenever
the nation of israel or an individual
had some kind of challenge or hardship
they would fast and pray
like before queen esther went in to see
the king and announced the nation of
israel fasted three days
and even daniel was fasting when god
sent gabriel with
the 70 weeks prophecy
and there's even a story where
the disciples
failed at casting out a demon and jesus
said this one only comes out by fasting
and prayer
so my question is
what is it about fasting
that
seems to lead to divine intervention
okay good question i think when somebody
fasts it's
setting aside something that um we
almost take for granted eating is is
something pleasurable we do it all the
time
but when we set that aside for a period
of time and we're focusing our attention
on requesting something special from god
it is the clearing of the mind it is
removing the distraction even though you
might be hungry but it's giving up
something
because you feel burdened your burden is
greater and you really are longing for
the lord to answer a prayer or to do
something for you
there is a blessing in fasting it's good
for you for most folks it's good for
them to fast if they're not a diabetic
but i think also just clearing the mind
being able to focus on something
specific you know professor carlos i
remember we had a church member a number
of years ago that was diagnosed with
cancer and he was just a pillar in the
church wonderful person he's one of the
elders
and it was a very serious diagnosis
and the elders of the church and the
pastors
they felt so strongly about wanting to
offer intercessory prayer for him that
they fasted we fasted for a week
and at the end of that week prayer and
fasting multiple people fasting and we
didn't eat any food just just liquids at
the end of that week the amazing thing
was that you went for another test
came back absolutely no cancer
whatsoever and the doctors couldn't
believe it well we we believe that was
because of the prayer and the fasting of
the of the believers in the church so
there is power in just simply doing what
god has said setting aside food focusing
attention on spiritual things and
earnestly uh interceding on behalf of
somebody else or if we have a special
spiritual need
asking god for the blessing of that i
know pastor carlos you're involved in
helping folks uh we've got a series of
meetings coming up and encouraging
people to fast now fasting doesn't mean
that you abstain from food all the time
right yeah you can fast other ways too
yeah there are partial fastings you
might fast from certain things that you
know are harmful for you and you've been
eating or
you can fast one day on one day off you
might fast breakfast only or lunch so
there's different methods and different
ways to fast okay very good yeah uh does
that help jeremiah
yeah thank you that that that was very
helpful all right thanks for your call
all right who do we have next next we
have mark from michigan you're on bible
answers live
uh good evening um my question is not
about predestination or election but i'm
kind of curious matthew 11 28 talks
about jesus saying come unto me all ye
that labor and are heavy laden and i
will give you rest so he's talking to
everybody for salvation but in matthew
22 14 it says for many are called but a
few are chosen and
i'm just wondering if all of us are
called to be disciples or not
and what the difference is in this case
okay let me talk about those two verses
the first one jesus says come unto me
all hear that labor and heavy laden of
course the gospel invitation goes to
everyone but the ones who are chosen are
the ones that respond to that gospel
invitation those who surrender their
lives to christ jesus said not everyone
says lord lord lent into the kingdom of
heaven but he that does the will of my
father in heaven so it's true the gospel
is preached we need to preach it to
everyone we need to give them the gospel
invitation but the only ones
the ones who respond to that gospel
invitation they are the ones who are
chosen meaning they have actually
responded but having said all of that
does god call all of us to be disciples
yes now that doesn't mean that god calls
all of us to go to foreign lands as
missionaries
he might call some of us to do that but
wherever we are whatever we do if we
claim to be a christian
we ought to be a witness we are to be a
disciple of christ and disciple makers
and god will reveal to us what area of
ministry he wants us to be involved in
whether it's the local church ministry
or whether it's giving bible studies or
witnessing or whatever it is we all need
to witness we all need to share our
faith so in that sense we're all called
to be disciples
okay
thank you all right thanks for call mark
next we have joyce from virginia you are
live welcome joyce
thank you for taking it i'm just asking
the question i was uh
someone said just laugh
say if you're not uh
baptized in jesus name you won't go to
heaven
and i i'm not sure about that okay good
question do you have to be baptized to
go to heaven well you know jesus said uh
no in jesus name oh in jesus name well i
think we need to
if you're not baptized in jesus name you
won't go to heaven okay well when
somebody's baptized usually what we do
is we follow the biblical
admonition jesus said baptized in the
name of the father the name of the son
and of the name of the holy spirit
so if you're going to baptize somebody
you want to baptize them in the name of
the father you want to baptize them in
the name of his son jesus christ and in
the name of the holy spirit the holy
spirit so
the exact wording i know some people
have an issue about how exactly you need
to say
those words when a person is baptized
but the bible is not focusing on how the
words are said it's what he said are we
baptizing are we committing ourselves to
the gospel message of the father son and
the holy spirit accepting jesus as a
personal savior so if somebody's
baptized the name of the father son and
holy spirit
that's that's perfectly legitimate
baptism if someone's baptized in the
name of the father the son jesus and the
holy spirit that's also perfectly
legitimate baptism so the exact wording
don't don't let the exact wording
um think that a person is not saved or
lost if if it's not said just perfect
does that help julie
i guess you hung up oh we got oh joyce
sorry it's joyce not julie does that
help joyce
yes it does help okay
it does help yes yes thank you joyce all
right i hit the wrong caller there who
do we have next
maybe we need to go to julie that's good
i'm mentioning that julie in south
dakota welcome to the program
well thank you hi pastor ross and hi
pastor carlos
my question tonight i was just wondering
if you would summarize the last days
events
leading up to the close of probation and
then when will probation close okay good
question all right first of all do we
know when probation closes the answer is
no there's no time prophecy in the bible
that tells us you know after so many
years or so many months probation were
closed but we do know that certain
events need to take place before
probation closes
several things we're looking at a
shaking taking place within christianity
within the church there is a separating
of those who truly love god and those
who don't
there is also a special outpouring of
the holy spirit that is to come we call
that the latter rain and that will
embolden the church there will be a
revival taking place amongst god's true
followers
there will be a loud proclamation of the
three angels messages first angel
worship god the one who made the heavens
the earth the sea the hour of his
judgments come the second angel babylon
has fallen he's fallen the third angel
if anyone worships the beast or his
image or receives his mark
so this loud proclamation you also see
in revelation 18 we call this the fourth
angel's message where the earth is
illuminated with god's glory all of that
takes place before probation closes
we also have the mark of the beast issue
that is uh also being enforced during
that time period before probation closes
god's people have the seal of god and
again the mark of the beast and the seal
of god it's symbolic it's not a literal
mark that people receive and then after
this loud cry is given and everyone has
had an opportunity to hear the gospel
and to make their choice as to which
side they want to be on
then probation closes after probation
closes then you have the seven last
plagues that you find recorded in
revelation 15 and 16
and the last of those seven plagues is
the actual second coming of christ
so that's kind of the sequence of events
we're looking for a revival in the
church we're looking for a special
outpouring of the holy spirit the gospel
is to be preached to all the world
you have the mark of the beast issue a
uniting of church and state
and then close the probation and then
the seven last plagues
does that okay well thank you so much
that really helped a lot i appreciate it
all right thanks phil cole
bye-bye bye-bye
next we have anthony calling from
michigan welcome anthony to bible
answers live
hello i hope your name is going splendid
hello
hello yeah yeah
oh okay you must not have heard me at
first i'm sorry yeah i hope you're i
hope your net is going wonderful um
i was just looking for scripture for um
some
anxiety that's been popping up here and
there during some tribulations i've been
going through i'm losing my home and i'm
about to be a father to my girlfriend's
kids take a shot at that we're moving
into a hotel so we got some
questionable circumstances or some not
so great circumstances although i have
been handling it better than i expected
to if this ever happened yeah well
anthony it sounds like yes you've got
you've got some challenges and i'm glad
you're you're listening to bible answers
live it sounds as though you're you're
open to seeking god's guidance and
looking for god's help you know the good
news is that we can never get as low we
can never be so overwhelmed with trials
and difficulties that we can't call out
to god sometimes we do need to kind of
hit rock bottom before
we're willing to allow the lord to work
i think the first thing you want to do
is
if you have not yet you want to get on
your knees and say lord you know i
commit my life to you
you want to ask god to lead in your life
you want to find good christian
fellowship connect with the church start
building relationships
and then just pray that the lord will
open up doors as you seek to follow him
and lead him
claim the promises of the bible jesus
said i'll never leave you no forsake you
the bible says if you lack wisdom in
james you can ask of god and he will
give if you need to make some decisions
take responsibility for your life take
responsibility for your choices that you
have made try to be you know the best uh
the best father that you can be
uh try to get a job and do the best you
can to provide for your family but then
also seek the lord seek his guidance and
he's leading and uh the lord will open
up the way you know we do have a book
that we'll be happy to give you
uh it's actually a book that was
recently written by pastor doug and you
need to call and ask for it it's finding
peace in a world of worry what to do
with trials and difficulties and we'll
be happy to send that to you you or
anyone who calls and asks just call
800-835-6747
and ask for the book finding peace in a
world of worry
and keep doing what you're doing keep
listening to the word of god keep
reading keep studying
get connected with a good church
and allow the lord to lead in your life
thank you call anthony
next we have richard you're live richard
welcome to bible answers live
hello
hi um
can you hear me yes loud and clear
good
um my question is concerning romans
chapter 11 verses 20 and 29
uh it says as concerning the gospel
they are enemies for your sakes but as
touching the election they are beloved
for the father's sakes
for the gifts and calling of god are
without repentance
um
i
suppose my my question is about well it
is my question is about the relationship
um
that god has to israel as as a nation
okay
um
re read this
verse
you know if you look back into the
history of israel it's pretty clear that
god loves the nation of israel way back
even in old testament times during their
rebellion against god
god would keep reaching out to them he
keeps sending prophet after prophet and
of course jesus came and christ
primarily prime primary i should say
focus was for the jews it was for his
people and he wept over jerusalem
because they rejected him their only
hope of salvation
and god still loves the jewish people
now as a nation
they have turned their back on god
there are many jews who accepted christ
as their messiah they of course become
part of spiritual israel
i think that before jesus comes i hope i
believe that there will be a revival
amongst many of the jews in jerusalem in
israel they'll come to accept christ as
the messiah but as a nation as a whole
their probationary time ended
in 34 a.d at the stoning of stephen when
they turn their back upon christ but it
doesn't mean that individuals can't be
saved paul is still saying that god
loves the jew god loves israel
and his purpose hasn't changed he still
wants to save them
and you know if you look at a nation
that has rebounded as a result of so
much trials and persecution no other
nation like israel has
come back and seems to be blessed uh in
so many things that that they do they
faced a lot of persecution because the
devil hates the jews
but yet you know god has given them
wonderful blessings and
i would
we know of of jews that have accepted
christ and they powerful preachers of
the word of truth and so
yes god loves the jews just as he loves
everyone but i think there's still a
special work
for jewish people who see jesus as their
savior
amen all right who do we have next we
have about a minute left karen from
oregon
welcome karen
hi karen you got about we got about a
minute
okay well it'll be real quick then i'm
i'm
wondering about guidelines on how to
keep my um eye on jesus my focus okay
during the day while i work all right
good question
first of all you begin by filling your
mind with spiritual things in the
morning so you take time to read the
word but you keep your eye upon jesus
through prayer it's not that you're
praying
all day long but throughout the day you
are sending up little prayers you're
turning your thoughts towards heaven and
um
you it's it's easy to get distracted
with earthly things you want to keep
drawing your mind back and you know if
we pray and say lord help me to to stay
on you the holy spirit will convict us
and say you know
think about spiritual things or send up
a little prayer
and ask for the holy spirit to help
guide you to remind you and if you hear
that prompting respond to it and god
will bless well friends you hear the
music playing in the background we want
to say goodbye to those who are
listening on satellite radio but for the
rest of you are listening on land-based
radio stations watching on af tv we're
going to be right back
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
hello friends welcome back to bible
answers live for those of you able to
stay with the program we're going to
take some of your email questions that
you have sent in we want to thank the
many of you who have sent in your email
question if you would like to send us a
question via email just go to the
amazing facts website or you can
actually email it to i see bal questions
at amazingfacts.org
just go ahead and email your bible
question and we will try and answer as
many as we can in the next two minutes
what do we have pastor carlos rachel is
asking should will we have our pets will
our pets be with us in heaven okay well
our pets be with us in heaven you know
the bible says i is not see nor ear
heard neither is it entered into the
heart of man the things that god is
preparing for those that love him now
whether you're going to have the exact
you know cat or dog in heaven that you
had on earth i don't know but what i do
know is that god knows the desires of
your heart he knows
your animal and if you get to heaven and
you see a dog that looks just like you
know your dog here on earth or has
similar character traits
whatever it is you will be happy when
you get to heaven god will meet your
heart's desire amen shelly is asking
ephesians 4 8 talks about jesus
ascending and taking captivity captive
who are the captives okay uh who are the
captives to read about in ephesians the
captors were those who were resurrected
at the time of christ's resurrection the
bible tells us that when the jesus rose
from the dead some of the graves opened
up and people rose from the dead they
are the first fruits of the resurrection
and they ascended with jesus to heaven
when it says christ laid captivity
captive meaning those who were held
captive by death or the grave
they were set free not everyone the the
general uh resurrection is at the second
coming but there was a smaller group
that were resurrected and
jesus took them to heaven amen
joseph is wondering if sinfulness is
part of human nature why should he
suffer
eternal damnation for something that is
of his nature okay well first of all we
don't have to suffer eternal damnation
jesus has made a way of escape
and the bible says if we accept jesus a
personal savior and surrender to him we
can have everlasting life whoever
believes on him so nobody needs to
suffer eternal damnation now why are we
born with the self sinful nature well
that's because of adam and eve's sin but
despite the fact that we are born with a
sinful nature trusting in jesus we can
gain the victory and we can have hope so
we can't use that as an excuse and say
well you know i have the sinful nature
and you know i'm not even going to
surrender to christ i mean christ has
the power to give us victory if we trust
in him and that surrenders a day by day
experience coming to jesus and
surrendering our hearts and our lives to
him then he's able to work within us a
work that we cannot do for ourselves
well friends thank you so much for
joining us at bible answers live again
we hope to join you next week god bless
bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your bible questions